pull up the story here from we have a
story from daily mail this one's big
Spooks infiltrate Silicon Valley
Facebook is riddled with ex-cia agents
including president's briefer who now
runs harmful content team so many ex-fbi
work at Twitter they have a slack
Channel and Google is Rife with xcia so
uh there you go the intelligence
agencies run the technology sector uh I
I guess I'll throw it to you uh Blake
having been involved in the tech sector
what do you see with this have you
personally witnessed anything like this
or what are your thoughts
I we have personally witnessed like
Google coming down and and being unfair
right so when we were trying to build
the small dollar fundraising email
operation we would find a
disproportionate amount of our
fundraising emails would get sent to
spam and Gmail well it's like that
doesn't happen to the Democrats right
it's not just anecdotal like we've seen
the data on this with with many
different conservative uh candidates so
it's uh it's just banal at this point to
say that big Tech has its thumb on the
scale like yeah big Tech hates
conservatives and we know that what what
really got me was uh you know the media
and Carrie and I were running against
the media of course and and they called
me an election denier for just talking
about how you know the hunter Biden
censorship like I think that did more
than almost anything else to to put Joe
Biden in the White House oh well Blake's
denying the 2020 election and then for
Elon to go buy Twitter and now
subsequent to this 2022 election of
course but in the Twitter files and now
it's like the sorted details are out
there it is just demonstrable fact that
people at Twitter were censoring this
information with the sole goal of
helping Joe Biden win office this is
just not a conspiracy theory anymore
it's just true former FBI in Twitter and
current FBI Baker and yeah I mean so
it's really bad and we need to
disentangle it and and and and look at
how hard the media is going after Elon
um Elizabeth Warren is going after Elon
right deep State yeah this article by
the daily mails worth reading because
what you see is Agent after agent after
agent after agent after agent and you
see in the named and you see them in so
many positions of power but those are
the ones that we know about what about
the ones that are undercover what about
the ones that we don't know about what
about the ones that are compromised at
high level positions of power so there's
multiple layers to this not just overt
agents and spies working inside of these
big Tech social media companies there's
a different layer to this that again not
only shapes their companies but shapes
the minds of America and and I could
make the argument here throughout the
last few years overall social media has
been a net negative for the American
people it has led to a mental health
crisis it has led to a lot of debauchery
it has led to the destruction of the
family unit it is leading towards what I
believe is the great reset which is
essentially just this kind of larger
ideas this larger agenda that is
absolutely screwing you over and only
empowering the government so
um they're using it it's a psyop it's a
psychological operation and you are the
Target and you are the victim well but
so if you could say social media is a
net negative in 50 out of 100 was
neutral anything below that becomes
negative how negative do you see it uh
social media 12 wow you so you think
it's horrible I mean that's really
really a bad 25 percent
25 75 Bad 25 good you think it's bad
there's some good that comes with it
pretty bad I somewhat disagree I think
it's actually slightly uh more good than
bad and that's evidenced by before
social media the intelligence agencies
controlled media as it was I mean you
saw that in the church commission right
that the planting of journalists at high
ranking positions in media organizations
with with the internet it created cracks
and then channels like this start to
pour through other other creators people
like Steven Crowder start to pour
through they can't control every person
who posts though they try so there is a
net positive in my opinion it is better
than it was before but overall when we
look at the larger effects and again my
estimate again to answer your question
12 to about 25 overall when we look at
how people are affected especially how
children are affected by this when you
when you see
um the mental health negative effects
when you see women harming themselves
because it's trendy when you see uh just
the level of less interactions that
people are having the overall effect not
just politically but socially
financially economically I think the
overall negative uh it's a negative
effect to be honest with you politically
there are more voices that that are that
people are able to hear but they're
squashing on those independent voices
and and making sure that they reach less
and less people well I think this will
be reversed everything you're saying as
soon as Blake becomes CEO of Twitter
then we're gonna say such a massive net
positive that the world becomes an
incident that's funny although I was
just going to say this is dynamic too
wherever you thought it was 75 25 50 50
right now it's Dynamic and I suspect in
20 or 30 years we'll know will this
internet and social media experience be
net uh you know liberatory will more
people be free and happy because of it
or will we be living in something like a
techno uh dystopia surveillance State I
mean look what happened to the children
look look at modern day children look at
look at attention deficitis deficit
disorder identity disorders identity
disorder look at the use of online adult
content by children look at those
effects that will be with children
rewiring their brains right now as
they're speaking to to have instant
gratification right to have their their
trophies to have uh just just
glamorizing them Living For The World
the living for the likes rather than
living for their communities living for
their families living for a future they
rather have this kind of you know a
selfie image of themselves glorifying
themselves rather than having an
importance on anything else around them
and let's talk about 30 or 40 years uh
Blake what do you think about neurolink
are you taking the chip I'm not taking
the chip I'm pretty skeptical I'm pretty
skeptical I like Elon isn't it um just
seems like uh seems like a
seems like a road you don't want to go
down like it's too bad like your brain
will get hacked yeah
for instance
it's one bad thing I guess if you're
well if you've uh uh you ever have you
heard of ghosts in the show yeah so uh
in this anime people's brains or eyes
can be hacked you could be walking down
the street and also you go blind
is bad when Elon talks about how
neuralink could cure people who have
like paralysis or whatever what people
don't seem to understand is that all
systems are exploitable and this could
mean as well
that they could do bad things to you
it's not just about the things it could
fix about the things that it could hurt
they could make you feel like depending
on the sophistication of a neural link
chip in your brain if it can cure
depression it could make you depressed
so you you think about how bad it could
get
it gets scary bad yeah I mean look at
the number of children having uh you
know a gender dysphoria that's been
going up as well that number is only
going to be going up from here what if
it could help people feel good about who
they are it could and it could it could
do really horrifying things where they
put you in a prison camp tell you to
execute the innocent children and then
you're like I can't do it then they
click a button on their iPad you go oh
this feels really good you know I think
like social media is not bad or good but
it's powerful and if it's used for evil
that's powerful evil and the neural
links like an acceleration of that yeah
neutrality Ian you shouldn't be chasing
what feels good you should be chasing uh
you know hard work dedication building
something growing something sacrificing
uh something in order to to have
something outside of yourself a lot of
problems with our society comes down to
I need instant gratification I need
instant uh likes I need instant
attention right now that's the route to
a lot of our problems
and that's the psychological trick that
they play on us in order to have us
engaged in these kind of larger uh
mirror devices I gotta I gotta give a
shout out to uh to Andrew Tate that's
that's the guy right Andrew Tate yeah
yeah
Cobra Tate he's got a video where he
said I just saw this viral clip he's
like my happiness is irrelevant when I
wake up whether or not I'm happy or not
happy it doesn't matter I have to do the
exact same thing and I'm like he's
absolutely right dude he's so humble he
comes off so aggressive and like
um like I guess hubristic he even says
that about himself but he was just doing
an interview where he was like dude I've
been a Pawn on the game for so many
years my coach would say run I would run
I would do exactly what I was told for
years of my life up at 4am run seven
miles I run seven miles I do exactly
what my dad tells me now he's in a
position where he can be himself and he
is the king of his environment just to
bring it back to the conversation we
were having his point is that your
happiness doesn't matter you have
responsibilities and so with the
internet instant gratification with
things like neural link that can make
you feel better these are shortcuts that
ultimately in my opinion will actually
lead to you being miserable and so if
you think about where neuraling gets you
you've got right now like the body the
fat acceptance moving the body
positivity stuff these are people who
are suffering these are people who are
more likely to experience cancer and
other health defects uh our health
health
um impacts due to their weight being
told to accept it and be happy with who
they are but it's causing them damage in
the long term you put a neuraling chip
in someone's brain and then they're
unhappy about something so you click you
you click the button and then all of a
sudden they're happy they're not going
to solve their problem I'll put it this
way pain is a good thing if you can't
feel pain people people think like wow
unless you there are people out there
who can't experience pain they can't and
so a lot of people say you're so lucky
and they go no I'm not I could bite my
tongue off like I stepped on a nail once
and didn't realize it they can they
can't many of these people Can't Sweat
because their body can't differentiate
between temperature not being able to
feel pain is a bad thing we don't like
pain pain sucks but it's an important
thing that when you feel it you can
correct whatever the problem being
caused is if you can't feel upset
anymore because the the chip is just
correcting the problem you're going to
become lazy uh you're going to have no
goals you're going to be laying around
and you're just going to be a fat blob
lying on the floor clicking the button
to feel good thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time